lots of news this weekend this morning
we're gonna start with the weather a
devastating weekend snowstorm has
crippled parts of the southeast the
region is not used to this kind of
weather especially this early in the
season so more than 230 thousand utility
customers are blacked out after heavy
ice and snow knocked down trees and
powerlines across the Carolinas and
Virginia oh that's an electrical
transformer that exploded in Oak Park
North Carolina knocking out power to
nearby homes
I couldn't tell they were excited or
afraid as much as 20 inches of snow fell
in the Carolinas leaving dangerous roads
for drivers this storm is blamed for at
least one death winter storm warnings
are up this morning in at least four
states snow sleet and rain are still
falling in many areas at this hour Meg
Oliver's in Fletcher North Carolina
that's just outside Asheville where the
cleanup is getting underway Meg good
morning to you gal good morning there
are nearly seven hundred utility trucks
here ready to launch within the hour to
help restore power to more than 150
thousand customers across the Carolinas
although there are nearly nine thousand
workers responding to outages Duke
Energy says it still could take days
before all the lights come back on
highway and utility workers are
scrambling to get roads and power lines
up and running this morning after an
early season snowstorm pounded the
southeast
the wintry blast dropped more than a
foot of snow across parts of the
Carolinas snarling traffic and stopping
18 wheelers in their tracks
Mike Richey spent the night in his truck
after getting stranded on the side of
the road what were the driving
conditions like last night terrible
terrible that's why we had to pull over
I just called my work and told him and
he's like what you guys got to keep
moving when it's snow and I'm like we
couldn't there's no way the weather
turned deadly Sunday afternoon when
police say a tree fell in a car in a
Charlotte suburb killing the driver 100
miles away near Raleigh a tree crashed
onto an apartment building sending three
people to the hospital
airports from Georgia to Virginia race
to keep taxiways clear and planes diced
while passengers inside the terminals
face more than 1,800 cancellations
hundreds more are expected today we
stopped to get gas and we got back on
the interstate and as we got matters
snorted the mouthwash Lynn Clarke was
traveling with more than a dozen members
of a missionary group when their bus
broke down near Asheville they huddled
for more than five hours without power
or heat at this truck stop waiting for
help to arrive
we knew God was gonna take care of them
they were in good spirits despite it all
a local church shelter brought them in
for the night now Duke Energy says they
are making progress as you can see
behind me is a very active site a lot of
people are coming in to work getting
ready to launch
they have already restored power to more
than three hundred and thirty thousand
customers John Meg thank you active site
indeed car going behind you and we're
glad that one I missed you earlier
thanks so much meg